hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play limbo okay got a spider to
murder lies ha ha ah
know that I push shift instead of
control all right take two ha ha ha
oh do ya that's more like it I gotta be
careful on his third leg cuz apparently
he gets a little angry that I chopped
off his other two hello hello
I have a special delivery for you it's
full of metal teeth come out nobody
knows
oh so sad for you Oh what what what wah
wah wah oh no ok and then I gotta be
like Miss mate
oh you're dead get that off
what's that you want some huh up you up
I'm gonna be carefully open do it it it
it it you're a minute I don't know if
it's just gonna instant ha ha ha got ya
but it's such a loser
oh yes right get out of here oh you're
not scary at all
not even a little bit ok so I'm out of
chopping charges hello to the dark
forest totally safe down okay not bad at
all
ok
spider leg up hopping over that don't
know what that was but I'm hopping over
it
Boeing ping pong ding-dong this is
pretty oh man hey come on let me move
ooh I don't like the sound of that
ah I know aah aah no aah what the do it
the fruit of rack let me out let me out
let me lad aah oh oh oh that that
doesn't seem good aah
boy that's duh that's that's bad how'd
you do your legs back that's really bad
oh I'm still oh this is what I'm
supposed to happen huh swing swing
aah ohh whoa hello okay whoa ha ha yeah
survival I am the best
Arnon gonna mess with me oh yeah
epically oh this is the silliest looking
thing ever
uh hell am I gonna get out of here I
can't even see where I'm going
lies Oh Eric Oh Oh app leap on the best
don't know how I knew that was there but
I dodged lots of little bug looking
things floating around on the screen in
the ground here don't know if you guys
could yeah and once again the noises are
necessary thank you very much wish Oh No
dammit okay that didn't happen
what that bad news okay no I just push
it over the crest and then I get them
breakup rock out of there
a puppet dick get out of that gather
gather yes easy peasy lemon squeezy 1.1
nice faster this way ha okay this makes
sense I know what I'm doing hello can
anybody go ah it's a thingy uh-oh
that's no good how does even know why is
he following me
hello seem to be missing some legs
aren't you a bit of a douche oh wait are
you I only see five huh get out of there
get out of here whoa oh there we go
whoa holy hell yeah suck on that get up
get up buddy
get up not knocked out yet okay stir got
a little piece on is it oh no all right
fine fine I'll just look
Taron own you know that's creepy shoulda
known okay
well the little boys go to die so how
this works
an epic loot ah not fair does it
I should have seen that Oh dodge Oh
epic dodge I should have seen that
coming
I wasn't paying attention well then
again I I should I should assume that
everything is trying to kill me in this
world because that's the way it seems to
go hello Oh a big leap Oh
epic parkour Oh sosa mazing look at me
go arms is the best up didn't we all
here did you oh yeah what's this then
Oh God good I know it just ah I knew it
was gonna crack but I didn't know it was
gonna crack write that in there
hope you okay oh that's a there's a body
right there you look in between those
logs snagged on something okay so now
I don't even think I maybe if I then I
get okay not that not that that was
wrong that was very wrong that was wrong
I'll predict it if you do oh yeah
then just when it snaps come on back
come on snap oh I got a jump on it there
we go
ah got it yeah suckle ah oh
I rot it grab it yeah what
baloney how about I do everything's
finally kill me if I just hang on here
or fall falling good to dictator hood
you dig up a ruse and then the tomatoes
hang well that didn't work either
if I jump yeah totally totes a jump on
totally made epic well that's not good
that's not good
oh my god yeah Oh who's the best oh the
greatest that would be me thank you
thank you ignore those three other
failures but whatever
Oh
ah I like a mechanic ah okay so then I
go by get up get out of the way up
ah hi good gut son of a [ __ ]
oh yeah get back here monkey shot a
monkey jaw mogees yeah Oh monkey job I'm
a monster
better Oh what was that I heard
something I heard some Oh
flaming tire diddly fire though
leap over the fire set another one
ah oh yeah miss me dig get out of here
don't lie to you anyway Oh Oh Moo get
you I'll get you monster
yeah murder you murder your dad murder
maybe maybe limbo is like the kid is the
monster the real monster
well I see that I see that
I see
I see those running it lock it I didn't
work running not headlong into it and
then coming back just a time but missing
all your dick Oh Oh father why the
husband well
oh why well my mother be your oh wait
the ropes duh the rope I'm Oh gujja I'm
coming to get you coming to get you
ah just missed it oh just missed it but
I could have gotten that if I was
quicker it was pretty close he's like
right there I'm gonna get you get your
jaw let's go ah ah
you get him before Oh ah ah
what did oh oh wait I was I was I was
there I was able to walk a little bit
ha ha ha I'm so scared I'm so get get
get up it nope oh I gotta push the log I
got hoo boo [ __ ] I have to push the log
push the log oh I don't have a lot of
time here do I hop epic oh yeah oh so
much I'm so far behind
why did you forget how to live want you
to do that uh oh
hello hi oh I get it
yeah never physical actual fish boo [ __ ]
boo [ __ ]
Oh so far behind oh oh wait a minute i
how do I not another leg off oh so bad
hope you're dead now that's why to
really want to kill me
blank have to protect the food yeah okay
now got this whiter taking care but I
think this might have Myrtle eyes those
little kids why didn't they team up with
me obviously I'm the badass they need me
I wonder what how what language this
game was made in it's like a Java game
or a C++ game or just if it's made off
of a custom engine or what because this
is really cool
and I think this game is about as
India's they come like on the
touchscreen
ah just hit one guy help me ah the
spider
oh it's only got one leg left how did
you even get here looks like a big daddy
longlegs everyone knows the deadlines
later ah ah ah come on spider yeah
oh when you're a dick up with it I'll
push you all push your eyeballs in oh
you're such a loser oh so much I'm uh
supposed to push you
oh I don't wanna touch the spider but
push I piss you I jump on you go ride
the spider hello jump on your leg jump
on your leg off break your leg
rah break it I'll break it Oh break the
leg
screw your leg man f you buddy what you
get so there are other kids in this game
but apparently okay apparently I can't
break
all right that's just a spider body it's
so gross what if I get a running leap at
it bish i bish you i boost your but
damage okay fine be that way all right
so I can't break it so what do I do
push some sort of physical response here
what do I do
I finish you I push you I booted you
what do i do not on it just like alright
hey let me let me see you like it I
think I pull you I pull your legs I told
ya but I'm so strong
uh-oh you're so dead oh oh oh it's so
freaky oh oh it's good fire body oh
that's so creepy
oh but I boost you oh this is like the
creepiest thing ever oh it's still got a
mouse ooh oh oh that's wrong
oh that's so wrong oh oh and it's dead
okay that's good place to end I'm all
the time oh yes
it makes your skin crawl it's just a
spider body but gigantic you put your
hands all over it it's faced it's
Bhushan it are anyway I'm a lot of time
thank you guys so much for watching hope
you're enjoying it and as always I will
see you in the next part
bye bye